we begin with the latest escalation in
the israeli-palestinian conflict gaza's
health ministry says that nine people
have been killed
calm now appears to be prevailing for
the moment this
alive shot from gaza earlier hamas fired
a barrage of rockets from the strip
they were launched in response to what
the group called israeli aggression
in the al-aqsa compound israel is
hitting targets across
gaza with artillery
earlier the al-aqsa mosque compound
islam's third holiest site was the scene
of a violent israeli crackdown these
pictures are from inside the mosque
israeli forces firing rubber-coated
steel bullets tear gas and sound bombs
that palestinian worshipers
and that's the second time that israeli
forces have stormed
the mosque since last week
[Music]
and these pictures are from in and
around the compound which houses the
mosque israeli security forces targeted
palestinian protesters
who were standing guard
the latest numbers from the palestinian
red cross are that more than 330 people
have been
injured speaking earlier israel's prime
minister benjamin netanyahu praised the
security forces for supporting what he
called
a just struggle at upholding law and
order
a struggle is taking place in the heart
of jerusalem this is not a new struggle
this is a struggle between intolerance
and tolerance between law breaking and
violence
and law and order the struggle is not
new because it has transpired over
jerusalem
and the heart of jerusalem for centuries
since the rise of the monotheistic
religions
for years one side ruled and excluded
the two others
and sometimes they changed and the same
thing happened
you can say that in the long history of
jerusalem only under israeli sovereignty
since 1967
we are witnessing a continuous stable
secure period in which we are working to
ensure freedom
of worship and tolerance for all
meanwhile organizers of an israeli march
to commemorate the 1967 occupation of
east jerusalem have cancelled their
rally
there have however been smaller groups
of settlers and right-wing activists
gathering on the streets but the main
march involving thousands of people
has been called off al jazeera's
ibrahim is live in ramallah for us in
the occupied west bank but first
let's speak with harry forces who's
outside the al-aqsa mosque compound
harry
a lot for you to draw together for us
here let's start with
six o'clock local time when as you were
on air
air raid sirens began to sound there in
central israel well that's right and if
we wind the clock back a little bit
before that there was a warning from
hamas's military wing
that if israel did not uh withdraw its
forces from the al-aqsa mosque compound
known as the temple mount to jews if it
didn't withdraw
from sheikh jarrah the neighborhood in
east jerusalem at the center
of this eviction dispute if it didn't
release the people it had detained
during the course of the day then come
six o'clock local time
there would be a price to pay that price
came in the form of
seven rockets that were fired towards
the jerusalem area
one of them was intercepted six fell in
open areas now this is a very
rare event for all of the escalations
and rockets we've seen
out of gaza in recent years uh it's not
thought of it happens in this part of
israel
or rather in the area to the west of
here
which is around the jerusalem area uh
there haven't been rockets targeting
that for several years
so that's a major escalatory step
as far as the israelis are concerned
there will be a response to that
the israeli military is saying that
there will be several days of fighting
in and around gaza they are ruling
nothing out including targeted
assassinations
of leadership uh of they're not ruling
out a ground campaign either
the fact they're saying several days
also carries with it perhaps a
suggestion that they're trying to put
some kind of a time limit on it
but it's very difficult to do that once
these
escalations start because whatever the
israelis do
is likely to bring a response from
inside gaza as well
another thing to tell you about a
serious explosion
deadly one inside northern gaza uh this
is
during the time that there are israeli
airstrikes going on indeed the israeli
military
uh showed a video of a strike from
above saying that it had targeted a cell
a terrorist cell as they called it
a hamas one inside northern gaza
targeting three
uh what they said were terrorists
however there was also
an explosion in beit hanun which killed
nine people according to the palestinian
health ministry including
three children now initially there were
reports that that was
an israeli strike there have also been
sources suggesting that it could have
been a malfunctioning
ordnance of some kind from within gaza
it's extremely unclear as to exactly
what took place there whether the uh the
video that's been tweeted out by the
israeli military
refers to the same incident or not uh
hopefully we will get some kind of
clarity
we are seeking that from the israeli
military to see if they can rule out
that they are responsible for what the
palestinian health ministry says is nine
deaths including three children
and after a day of uh more violence
there in occupied east jerusalem has the
cancellation of this uh this march to
commemorate
the 1967 occupation of east jerusalem
done anything
to diffuse tension
yes it's it's strange really after these
days and days of building pressure and
tension
reaching this boiling point in the
al-aqsa mosque compound earlier
on monday now that we're on the verge
potentially of a very major escalation
between israel
and hamas in gaza the situation here at
damascus gate
on the fringes of the old city is the
calmest that it's been for some time
i think uh that is to some extent
because
of the uh decision to cancel this march
monday was
always worried about as a potentially
very combustible day because
of the march carried out traditionally
on this day
by jewish israelis particularly
religious nationalist and far-right
israelis
celebrating the 1967 capture of east
jerusalem
what they call the reunification what
palestinians consider to be
and international law considers to be
the military occupation that began here
in 1967. if that had been allowed to go
on through the muslim quarter of the old
city
there could have been very serious uh
exchanges of violence between the two
communities that that seemed a very
real possibility up until the last
minute the israeli security
establishment seemed to
go back and forth as to whether they
were going to allow it to take place
in the end at the last minute they
decided no that does represent some
significant
setbacks as far as benjamin netanyahu
and the israeli right wing is concerned
jews were not allowed access onto the
al-aqsa mosque compound the temple mount
on this
important day for them they've uh also
stepped back on this front they've
cancelled
a court hearing that was due to take
place today a supreme court hearing
on the evictions at
just a short distance away from here
and yet we have this potential major
escalation
taking place uh as a result partly
of what we've seen throughout this month
of increased tensions
and of course there was what took place
the very violent scenes that we saw
on the al-aqsa mosque compound itself
earlier on monday
al jazeera's harry fossett there live in
occupied east jerusalem we heard from
israel's prime minister benjamin
netanyahu a short time ago while the
palestinian leadership
has also been reacting to the heightened
attention
let's bring in nida ibrahim is live for
us in
ramallah in the occupied west bank so
anita what
has the palestinian leadership had to
say today
earlier on monday monday the
spokesperson of the palestinian
presidency nabila bourdain has said that
israel
is challenging the u.s administration
that is trying to calm the situation
down
and it's also challenging the
international community and when it
comes to the point of the international
community
we've had a chat with the plo's
executive committee member ahmed
majdalani
who says that the international
community's response and reactions
weren't strong enough to enforce israel
to calm the situation
down and he says that the condemnations
aren't
enough when it comes to that serious
escalation we've also heard from uh
different palestinian officials
including a top
aide to president abbas he tweeted
saying that the palestinian leadership
is going to convene and study
what options they have to confront the
israeli escalation
in occupied east jerusalem but that has
been met with a lot of criticism in the
street
where b people say that they've been
calling
for gaza to respond and they've seen a
response
from the military wings of hamas and
islamic jihad in gaza
while the palestinian authority is still
studying
what to do this is this
these sarcastic remarks we've seen them
a lot on social media
and there is some feeling that the
palestinian authority can do more but
isn't but when it comes to palestinian
officials they will tell you that they
are seeking
a the international community they want
the u.n security council the arab league
and the organization of islamic
cooperation
to deal with the situation and kind of
put pressure
on israel on that regard we've also
heard from
the palestinian prime minister mohammad
who condemned the escalation
let's hear what he had to say in the
beginning of the weekly government
meeting
i hold the israeli government fully
responsible
for what the worshipers were exposed to
in the blessed al-aqsa mosque
and i warn of the consequences that will
result from such incursions
as well as attempts to evacuate the
people of sheikh
shara the original owners of the land
from their homes
i call on the international community to
intervene
immediately to stop these horrific
violations
and to provide protection to the
citizens of the palestinian territories
especially in the city of jerusalem
which is undergoing
ethnic cleansing today jerusalem is
restoring
the glow of the cause and one of the
people
of uh ramallah nida have they been
reacting to all of this
well throughout the past 24 hours and
even before that we've seen
lots of spontaneous protests all across
different cities from the occupied
west bank including protests here in
ramallah where
we've heard people chanting slogans in
support
of those in east jerusalem and sheikh
jarrah
chanting for freedom for palestinians
and for
them not to be evacuated from their
houses but we've also seen many
denouncing the oslo agreement this is
the agreement that has been signed
between the palestinians and israelis or
rather the plo and the israelis that
allowed
for the establishment of the palestinian
authority in the 1990s
and there is a growing feeling among
palestinians that the palestinian
authority isn't doing much
when it comes to their live under
occupation
so we've heard also calls for protests
uh for from palestinians who want uh
these protests to
go to confrontation poets near league
sorry near israeli military checkpoints
and illegal israeli settlements to kind
of confront
with the israeli military because they
they know that
although they can't go to jerusalem it's
surrounded by israeli military
checkpoints they need prior
permits to be able to enter it and some
of them never get it
but they believe that it's important for
them to voice their anger
their cause is the same cause they all
believe that they're suffering under the
israeli occupation
and that's why they want to to have
their voice heard
and they want to voice their anger
al jazeera's nida ibrahim reporting live
from
ramallah in the occupied west bank ada
many thanks indeed